[Music]
as has been said my name is Andre I'd
like to talk about scaling data frames
and you may have noticed this blog post
on the stack overflow blog last year in
September where they talked about why is
it that python is actually so popular
these days because that wasn't the case
just five or six years ago and they
found out that one of the main reasons
for this is the is the growth of the of
the panas package they even added this
nice chart we can see for example django
being pretty much stagnant over the time
period with panda's non-payment map up
in the whole pi data ecosystem emerging
and a lot of talks over the past two -
days have been on machine learning ai
and and other technologies that
basically build on this on this under
sort of baseline of pandas and other
technology so we sort of take these for
granted because these are some sort of
data data containers and data
manipulation mechanisms that we don't
really talk about anymore because we get
we've grown so used to them so before we
get to the whole scaling part let's just
talk a bit about what are data frames
and why do we like them so I presume
that everybody here uses data frames so
at least the vast majority so I don't
really wanna explain I just wanted to
give my give my take on why I've enjoyed
using them over the past five or six
years so as you all know these are in
memory data structures so this is sort
of implicit analogous explicit
comparison to how we think of for
example sequel databases so so these
offer a lot more flexible schema so for
example if you if you want to do all
sorts of trans positions and pivots it's
a lot easier in data frames there is a
very nice domain-specific language so
while sequel as a language is is very
nice unreadable this programmatic access
to data in data frames this has has a
lot of benefits as well also the UDF so
user-defined functions so in in data
frames you can use the the power of
Python to basically manipulate your data
as you wanted
you can do a similar thing in in the
various various implementation of sequel
but these languages tend to be a lot
more limited and also a lot harder to
debug and extend there's no runtime
there's no connection pools no
maintenance it's really it all lives
within the process that you run so it's
it's a lot more flexible in this in this
way it's also all the data is a store
per column which which offers very
efficient columnar processing which
we'll get to in a minute it's not tied
to specific data so meaning that Hennis
doesn't really care where your data is
because it loads allows it all into
memory into its own format and you can
also combine most latest data sources
which again you can do in sequel for
example in Postgres with foreign data
represent technologies like these in
pandas you can it's it's a lot more
extensible because you can have some
data from CSV some from Jason some from
a database and combining together so
these are some of the benefits and some
of the things that we like about data
frames but there's this thing that a lot
of people get to is that we we do tend
to use functions like read CSV with JSON
and and and other methods to get our
data data into data frames but similar
to the graph were where it showed the
explosion of the popularity of pandas if
you showed for example the average data
data set in terms of size you would see
a similar graph so the size of data has
exploded over the past few years and so
if you do a read CSV on a 100 megabyte
CSV it's not a problem on a regular
laptop well once it gets to ten
gigabytes hundred gigabytes you're going
to start to struggle so over the years
I've faced this issue multiple times in
multiple areas multiple domains and I've
tried several different approaches to do
to overcome this and there's one thing
to emphasize there's no
one-size-fits-all solution so some
people try to claim oh this is you know
this is your data frame API the that
works for everything but there's now
always downsides and I want to be clear
on that and I want to explain what they
are for each of the technologies that
I'm gonna be talking about right so
these are the solutions so
one is not something that you subscribe
for so they won the first one is
actually not scaling at all it's
actually just changing your code to to
avoid all that pain
the other one is scaling up so also
known as vertical scaling so getting a
beefy machine scaling the data so it's
also quite handy which is basically just
improving the the source of the data and
to do all the not all but many much of
the heavy lifting and the last part is
has been quite popular over the past few
years and that's just actually using
distributed systems so horizontally
scaling by adding nodes to your to your
system so the first point was actually
not scaling so changing record so not
actually not scaling up we're out the
reason for this is pandas is fast so
West makini the author has done a lot of
a lot of optimizations that you don't
really see when you when you're working
with pandas day to day but there's
actually a lot worried like that went
into this but the thing is the problem
is well us when we're doing right right
: we try to manipulate individual data
points and writing slow code to do so so
when you're working with data frames you
can try to apply your own code to do
some manipulations you always have to
keep in mind that all the columns are
store in a columnar fashion and it's
it's really good to to use vectorized
functions so this slide is more about
the the compute compute intensive
workloads the other one it's going to be
about about memory memory in terms of
workloads so in terms of CPU intensive
workloads a if you if you treat the
columns as basic vectors of values then
it's gonna speed up your code I've seen
I've seen speed ups of of 100x even more
so we've seen people looping through
their individual values of millions of
values in a column and applying some
simple functional a simple function to
each value and then saving it back
whereas if they use syntax like this or
working with the columns as as a whole
suddenly they went from a couple minutes
to a couple hundred milliseconds and
also if you're if you're doing a lot of
retrieval from your data frames and just
saving it back again with a with a
little bit of modification then you
should maybe consider not using data
frames data frames for this workload and
just taking a taking it out and then
reconstructing the data
once your work is done we've done this
many times and also we've seen ten x
hundred x performance increase in that
so that was that was cpu pressure
because you know as you know there's
there's there's a variety of variety of
performance problems so that was cpu
pressure this is more about the memory
pressure because as you know the pan has
loads the whole data frame into memory
so at that point you you can ask
yourself do you actually need all that
data in memory at once because you know
if the data set is hundred gigabytes and
you've got a run-of-the-mill laptop
that's not gonna happen so there's a few
questions that you asked so do you need
all the data in memory at once
often times the answer is yes but
sometimes it's no the second point is do
you actually need all your data because
sometimes when you've got when you don't
need like a let's say a sum of or
account of visits per client for per day
or something like that then you need all
your data to do that but times you just
need to know what's my was the correct
character what are the characteristics
of my of my data set what's the I don't
know error right if you're looking at
your logs or something like that so you
don't need all your data for that if
you've got correct sampling mechanism
then you can get away with just looking
at at some samples of your data you have
to be very careful to sample correctly
so otherwise you're gonna be inducing
bias into your analysis by only
selecting some data or not not other and
the third point is do you actually need
all your columns because often times
that's not the case and you can actually
throw away a lot of data whilst you're
loading your data into your data frames
so if you look at the documentation for
read CSV there's you can use only
specific columns and if you don't need
all your memory all your data in memory
at once you can actually just specify
chunks of data that you're gonna be
reading one at a time and then you're
basically looping over chunks of data
and you can process hundreds of
gigabytes of data on a on a regular
laptop so that's that's useful for
example when you're doing some sort of
filtering and you're just gonna want to
want to export you're a subset of your
data into a different one with some like
processing and last but not least
there's data types so panas is a lot
more efficient with memory if you're if
your data is is saved as primitive types
of permit
as being being all your floats and intz
and these sorts of data types are then
panis stores it in a in a numpy numpy
array which is very efficient whereas if
you if you've got strings lists and
objects and that sort of stuff then it
stores a pointer to a Python object
there's you know boxing and everything
and it gets very bloated
bloated very quickly and also there's
Cara categorical types which is
basically you've got a column that can
only have attained a limited set of
values so for example like a country
then you can set it to be a categorical
so instead of you know saving pointers
to to the strings for each for each
value it actually for each value its
store is like a number so it just says
oh the Netherlands number one Czech
Republic number two etc and then just
stores the numbers in an umpire array so
and you can do that whilst you're
loading your data if you if you set it
as categorical or you can do it once the
data is loaded there's a few methods to
working for working with categorical
data in pendous and now for a bit of
heresy do you actually need finders for
your for your for your for your work
because so I used to work as an analyst
and I used pandas day-to-day because
it's it's got a very nice API in a work
great for all my in memory needs but now
now that I work as a data engineer I'm a
bit more aware of the resources that my
code utilizes and often times I realize
I don't need the API I don't need my
data in memory not even chunks of it I
can do the purse thing in a streaming
fashion again this is not for every
workload but for a lot of workloads it
can be the case that you don't really
need hand us and you can you can you can
even use the standard library in Python
which includes gems like collections and
air tools this isn't the kind of
standard like that in the Python
standard library so in case you haven't
checked that out be sure you do because
it's got very nice functionality for for
data processing and lazy execution that
sort of stuff and I've seen seen people
use pandas as a CSV reader as a very
very powerful CSV reader so if that's
that's all you want that there's the CSV
package in Python so let's get to the
actual scaling so
it might sound a bit amusing that I'm
actually suggesting that you get a
beefier machine but I used to work at
this company a couple years ago we
didn't have laptops we only had
workstations and once upon a time I got
you know doubled doubled Aram I got a
faster SSD and I got to do my work a lot
faster it was a couple hundred euros
that that was spent on me and I didn't
have to have a virtual machine running
to do my analysis and it it amortized
really really quickly so it might be
costly up front but if you've got a I've
got a system that's easily extensible so
it's not like a an ultrabook but if
you've got a workstation this is
something that can actually speed up
your analysis a great deal and you're
not gonna be spending a lot of money
because she can burn through a lot of a
lot of cash on in the cloud so that's
that's the local scaling and all let's
get to the more interesting and remote
scaling and by that I mean I mean
getting Virtual Private servers so so
who here uses Jupiter and who has
deployed Jupiter other some in some
other instance than your laptop ok so
there's there's quite a good overlap so
just tell me from if I'm saying
something that you already know but this
is a this is a method that's very that's
very useful if you if you want to do
some ad hoc work and you don't want to
eat and for example you don't have a
DevOps team launching Virtual Private
servers has gotten a lot easier over the
past few years and it's a very elastic
solution it's got it's got an away
better billing at this point so I'm I'm
here I'm noting billing per hour but you
can actually get for a second billing on
AWS and GCP and on Google you get very
fast internet so for example if you if
you're processing data for example like
Wikipedia dumps and other and other
external sources then you're gonna
you're gonna have a lot better network
performance than on your machine and you
can even get some savings if you're in
secondary markets and stuff so that was
a discussion about this just a few weeks
ago when somebody just said oh you don't
actually need your big fancy distributed
systems because you can actually get a
machine that's
a terabyte of RAM on habius it's
actually not even the beefiest machine I
think you've got you can get up to like
4 terabytes of RAM
in some cases but then there was another
good point by John miles white from
Facebook that yeah that's all cool but
once you get beyond the the terabyte
which is it's gonna get a lot more
complicated for you so you gonna have to
change your workload so there's you know
pros and cons to every solution so in
case you've ever tried to deploy
anything on idea but yes this is what it
this is what it looks like and it looked
even worse so just a couple years ago
and you had to configure a lot of things
like what are you know what are subnets
you know you're I enrolls and shutdown
behavior what sort of storage you want
do you want block storage do one SSDs
etc and even if you just click through
and just go yeah yeah I want that you're
not gonna be able to ssh into it because
you don't have a report for ssh open so
it's it's a bit it's a bit tricky if you
if this is not your your daily bread but
gets their work done then ditch the
ocean came to came to be just just a few
years ago and they simplified it to this
so basically say oh cool I want four
gigs of RAM and two CPUs that's fine 80
gigs of SSD and I'm gonna pay $20 a
month whereas in you know ec2 co2 you're
sort of charged for it for every every
subsection of your so you know for for
your storage separately from your
computer etc so this was suddenly
basically anybody could deploy a machine
and run the analysis on it and it was
basically a revelation for quite a few
people Amazon realized this and this is
they're they're offering as well so this
is this is AWS lightsail which is a
similar similar offering to digitalocean
which is you can large easy basically
ec2 instances with predefined defaults
fairly saying same default for very ad
hoc work if you don't have a DevOps team
so you've got your virtual private
server what do you do now so I would
recommend just using certificates not
password so for example by default is
the ocean will ship your password in
your email
which by which has to be changed once
you once you log in actually forces you
to do so but once you get to
certificates that's that's a lot safer
solution obviously you need to add your
or you should add your user etc and once
you install Jupiter there's there's at
least two options that you can use it so
you can actually just you know go to
your the IP of your of your machine
specify the port and luckily as of a
couple of versions ago well if you
installed Jupiter just two three years
ago it would just you know open up so if
somebody was port scanning your well if
somebody was port scanning the the
eyepiece where VPS gets get deployed
they could get your you know wide open
Jupiter instance right then and there so
luckily they introduced token so once
you launch a Jupiter once you launch to
Jupiter instance it sort of requires you
to enter this one-time password so
there's at least some security but it
but still it's a it's all over HTTP so
it's it's not encrypted so while you
might be thinking I'm just saying code
back-and-forth actually the results of
your code actually get get shipped as
well in the JSON that is the ipython
notebook or Jupiter notebook so it's
better to secure it so either you can
you can set up HTTP on your server or
this is actually my favorite solution
and that's SSH tunneling so what you can
do is you SSH into your machine and you
tell it and you tell your local machine
oh if you if you want to reach this port
actually ask this machine that I've
already authenticated to using
certificates and everything so it's
going to go through so all the so all
the traffic is going to go through its
gonna go through security SSH but you're
just you just have localhost and your
browser buddy actually reaching your
your power powerful server in the
background last but not least you can
you need your your data to to actually
work on so there's there's a few options
a very good option is is object storage
so things like s3 or Google Cloud
Storage your things go and it's
extremely cheap for for a lot of
workloads for a terabyte of storage per
month you pay something like 20 dollars
and you can get even cheaper if you
don't access it frequently the only
thing you have to worry about
egress so the traffic outside of AWS or
your provider in that case because that
can get very expensive very quickly they
usually provide free traffic or cheap
traffic within the ecosystem so if you
launch if you want to use as three I
would recommend using ec2 for for your
computer so that you get free traffic
between the two you can also get other
other solutions like block storage along
getting get into that so
so that was scaling up remotely this is
actually an odd one but it worked great
for in a couple of instances it's
actually scaling the the data source
that you're accessing so this allows you
to still work on your laptop but crunch
terabytes hundreds of terabytes of data
without breaking a sweat well your
laptop's not gonna break up with some
other machine will and you can use this
simple function of read sequel query
where you just specify a connection to
your to your VP database in the
background and a sequel query and it's
going to return you a data frame that
you can work on so you get all your data
types because it's usually some some
schema my database and but obviously you
get limited EDF support because this is
all depends on the on the date on the
data store that you have in the
background and you need to add the
pipeline's in terms of you can't just do
you know read CSV and then you start
filtering etc so at this point you have
to do all the filtering and aggregations
within the the sequel query because you
can't be shipping the terabytes of data
on to your laptop you year you're
sending back an aggregation which I'm
gonna get into and you probably want to
use your everyday database like like a
Postgres or my sequel though you could
and we have and it is still quite
powerful but if you want to if you want
to scale out a bit a bit more as the
specialized technology for that so so
what you have to do is you have to do
some sort of sampling or aggregation or
aggregation and then sampling because as
I said you can't ship the terabytes of
data but it works it works very nicely I
I realized that we could do this once
we're so we're working with with Tera
data and redshift and we were just
running queries and just saving it as CS
and loading into pendous and they
realize oh we can just do that in once
well in one step so you the only thing
that we sort of set up at this point was
some sort of caching like if I already
asked for this data today then don't ask
again but that was just to save some
work on the on the database but this is
something that you can get that you can
set up very quickly there's a few
implementations of of data source that
can help you with this sort of workload
they differ in terms of the workflow so
right chief in snowflake are more for
like data warehousing and 24/7 runtimes
requiring Athena are are are amazing
technologies where they way actually
you're not paying much for storage and
you're only paying for the data that's
processed by the technology so so you
pay $5 per terabytes processed if you've
got your data stored as columnar you're
only paying for the columns that you're
scanning within the query so this is
very good if you sort of if you're an
analyst you don't have DevOps team
you're only running you know some sort
of work on the weekends so you save a
ton of data on s3 you run a few queries
you pay one or two dollars per month and
and you're all doing this from your
laptop so this is an amazing solution
for that kind of workload if you if you
this is something you're doing day to
day at work something like retro for
snowflake might be a better better fit
if you have a DevOps team and you can
you can experiment experiment a little
bit more there's open source solutions
like hive presto presses very popular
these days or drill which which offer
you similar functionality two to the two
to four technologies above and actually
Athena from AWS is is basically
rebranded presto so so the great thing
about this is that it works equally well
for a hundred million well not equally
well but it works similarly for you know
100 megabyte data set as as for a
hundred gigabyte a cell or even beyond
in in the case of retro for stuff like
the one thing to notice is that the
latency will be noticeable so if you
used to pan us and it's you know
results in 100 200 milliseconds it's not
something that you're going to get it's
going to be the latency is going to be
in seconds and as I said the pricing
model
are bit different so summer for some
some solutions are for 24/7 runtime some
some of them are for ad-hoc analytics
I said cached results so that you don't
have to query the database all the time
and whilst I said that you need to run
sequel there's actually technologies
like ibis from west makini which is
trying to sort of blend it together
where you basically tell I abyss this is
my this is my data source we did into
the into my data frame but whilst doing
so filter on these on this and this and
do these sort of counts in a panda's API
and it sort of translated that into
sequel and and executed on your behalf
and if you set up some data solution
like this it's also going to benefit
your BI tools like tableau etc because
then other people can use it as well not
just you and last but not least I'm
stressed for time this is the
distributed system which is something
that's been popularized in the past few
years by desk from anaconda and spark or
PI spark from the Apache foundation so
these are tools where they're trying to
blend in the this sort of getting be few
machines and and still retaining the did
a frame API we're done having to to to
write sequel so you're scaling
horizontally so you're getting more
nodes but you're still writing the day
of fame API code the benefit is they can
scale very nicely up and down because if
you get if you scale up what I get a
beefy beefy machine that you need to run
24/7 that's gonna get fairly expensive
off-peak or like at night if you don't
if you're if you're like if I like a
nine-to-five job whereas these can just
scale down to a single node overnight
and and then scale up a becket get back
again and they can even scale during
queries so if you've got a large query
that's person understood gigabytes you
can actually register the pressure on on
memory and CPU and just start scaling
and just start scaling out up until a
given limit but I think the best benefit
is that you've got the same API for a
single node as as you do for a
distributed system so you you're writing
some spark code on your laptop and then
you're like oh I actually
to run this on my whole production did
data set so you just move this code into
your into distributed system which could
be a notebook interface it depends on
what you're running and you're not
changing a single line of code and
that's not just you know like an ads hog
this is actually something that we've
done very successfully and the way they
these these things work is that when you
do your reach us via read something it's
not actually not actually reading
anything it's actually waiting for you
to specify or your filters aggregations
and UDF's and everything and it's only
when you actually want to take the the
results out of the system so you want to
print something you want to save it into
a CSV or some or some place and at that
point the the system triggers basically
it tries to compile a add a cord a
direct directed acyclic graph of actions
and tries to figure out what can what
can a paralyzed button does it need to
collect the data back like in a
MapReduce kind of fashion and at that
point it starts executing it so you
actually you read CSV then you write a
hundred lines of code but nothing has
been loaded and only once you print it
is it actually gonna start doing some
work in terms of the architecture SPARC
is a Scala or JVM system but it has very
close integration with Python and in
that in create integration has improved
over the past few years years when the
authors of SPARC realized that Python
has grown in popularity within data
signs so the Python API is actually very
nice and actually allows you to specify
UDF's and with inspark in Python and it
actually talks to the Python process
back and forth and it works quite well
of course that desk is is just Python
it's by the guys over at anaconda and it
actually implements much of the Python
much other pendous and numpy api so you
can you know you're writing some some
run-of-the-mill panda's code but then
you just import panas or the data frame
class from desk as opposed to from
pandas and it mostly works so there's
there are a few differences but but they
but the key is that it looks and
he's like pandas so it's it's very nice
if you want to if you want to port your
code to a to a cluster very quickly so
how do you get this up and running so as
of last year you can pip install both of
them which is quite amazing for spark
which is a bunch of jars but they
actually manage to move it up to two pi
pi and you can pip install pip install
PI spark we can spot they've installed a
scan both of them we're gonna work well
with on your laptop you can debug stuff
you can you can write all your code on
your laptop and then just get a
distributed system to run it if you want
to scale out there's a few solutions
like Amazon or AWS EMR there's data
backs which is the the authors of spark
data park from google HD insights from
Azure so there's a there's a whole bunch
of solutions that you can get and and
get up and running within within hours
so what to expect as I said there's no
there's no silver bullet there's no
one-size-fits-all so whilst you get a
lot better scaling so there's there's
this few limits to that and it's very
easy to migrate from your laptop to your
to a cluster you do you do get a higher
latency as I said it doesn't really load
the the data upfront unless you actually
tell it to which I wouldn't recommend
for larger data sets so you do get that
higher latency stuff you used to sort of
very reactive work this is not something
that you usually get in in the spark or
desk and also it gets the debugging gets
gets a bit harder because they the
person is not done on us on a single
note in a single process it's actually
get to distribute it so it's a bit bit
difficult to gather all the
instrumentation so what you what should
you do so there are four solutions as I
said there's no silver bullet and we've
used every single every single one of
these solutions for a different problem
and it served us very well
so I would I wouldn't recommend to go
with one and just you know apply to
every single problem that you see I
would also think about all the costs not
just the hardware because you know you
can get your Athena or your bigquery for
five dollars per terabyte but if you
spend three three three weeks debugging
it and you know think about the
engineering costs I'll also try to
simplicity so you can get a very
complicated system so you can you can
start writing very complicate
that's more efficient than than pandas
aggregations as I suggested in the first
point but then wouldn't just be easier
to just throw that desk and and let it
figure it out within minutes and this is
something that da Mouse burger
recommends in the link that I'm gonna
just show you and also planning planning
carefully if you if you need some sort
of collaboration so these tools you know
lend themselves to collaboration while
some of them and some some domes so
that's something to consider as well
there's some further reading so this is
the one about scaling panda so this is
this is about desk and this is about you
know you could write complicated code
that's gonna be a lot faster than pandas
but it's it might be worthwhile just to
just use desk or spark for that Mark
Twain chick he he sort of benchmarks a
lot of the lot of the databases that are
meant for analytical purposes so like
all those redshifts and click houses and
and big queries of the world and it's
it's got very nice charts and tables and
all sorts of stuff and a few and a few
other articles and talks I'm gonna link
to the slides should be on the website
at some point so you never see note it
down and that's all for me thank you
very much
yes thank you very much for the talk oh
there are any questions yes if you're
using dusk and you have big datasets and
you have separated from your working
notes should you keep it closed
why you should keep it closer to the
work well just to emphasize desk desk is
actually the only technology that I
haven't used from the from the whole
talk but judging from the judging
judging from the from the way spark
works you should you should just keep it
closer to the work who knows because
those are going to be the ones that are
going to be accessing the data and again
talking about spark if it's for example
within a Hadoop ecosystem it knows about
the colocation of the DSO so it knows
about you know because it asks where is
the data located and tries to co-locate
it with the with the with the execution
but if you're using for something like
you know object storage like a suite it
doesn't really matter because it just
pulls the data to your worker but you
know in general it should be closer to a
worker because the coordinator just you
know it designs the graphic design it
schedules the whole thing and it just
gives the metrics and everything but it
it usually doesn't do much of the work
if any okay thank you any more questions
all right then I would like one more
round of applause
[Applause]